Oriol winter loves her tattoos they all
have significant meaning for me the 18
year old Modern Family star got personal
with ET explaining the meaning behind
her body I only have five they all have
significant meaning for me I think it's
a super fun way of expressing yourself
I love getting tattoos I only get
tattoos that are really meaningful to me
and I love it
this is October 3rd 2012 which is the
day I moved in with my sister and it
kind of started like a new chapter of
life for me so it's really important I
have a spade on my wrist because I love
playing cards like more than anything
it's my favorite thing to do I I've been
playing poker since I was six years old
so my grandmother actually taught me
when I was young so I had this made for
her I'm Tiger on my back because I've
always felt like I've been like a
protector for other people and I've
always had these amazing protectors in
my life I have all of my nieces and
nephews initials on my side and then I
have a quote that says lovers to
everything and asked for nothing in
Greek